[Musica]
inizierò subito con una breve storia zen
nello zen le storie sono usate come
meditazione si chiama la tazza vuota un
eminente professore universitario si
recò da un maestro zen per chiedere
consigli sulla mutevolezza della vita su
continuo cambiamento quindi come
affrontare questo continuo cambiamento
nel qui e ora
ma anziché aspettare il maestro e le sue
risposte incominciò da una parte
giustamente a esporre le sue idee i suoi
concetti il suo modo di stare nel qui e
ora i suoi programmi di vita per
affrontare la realtà
il maestro rimase un po in silenzio poi
prese una brocca di te e incominciò a
versare nella tazza dell'ospite il the
bears aversa ed è fuoriesce dalla tazza
va per terra non vedi che è tutto pieno
seccato il professore di essere in nella
suo eloquio no è interrotto la tazza e
assolutamente colma eh si caro mio disse
il maestro come questa tazza e colma e
non posso mettere nuovo te la tua mente
è troppo ricolma delle tue idee
che cosa ci dice questa breve storia zen
questa meditazione che la prima cosa da
fare per affrontare la vita per essere
adesso vogliamo creativi innovativi per
essere nel qui e ora e liberare un po la
nostra mente e la meditazione è il
programma più centrato per questo ci
sono sicuramente tanti altri programmi
che si occupano di mente di riordinare
di aggiustare i nostri pensieri dire
impastarli però ben sappiamo che i
rimpasti in politica nella vita nella
le attività poco funzionano e allora la
mente diventa fattore per la meditazione
importante di studio di approfondimento
perché da pulizia da vuoto da silenzio è
da lì che può nascere la nuova idea come
quando noi facciamo un lungo viaggio in
macchina tagli andiamo la macchina la
prepariamo lo stesso con il nostro corpo
no facciamo running facciamo spesso dei
check up ci occupiamo di fare palestra
di mantenerci in buona salute insomma ci
occupiamo solo del corpo però poi quando
dobbiamo aprire il bagagliaio della
nostra macchina
la nostra mente e non riusciamo a
mettere i bagagli per fare il nuovo
viaggio perché perché troviamo catene
della neve che non usiamo più da anni
perché abbiamo le gomme da neve
troviamo tre ombrelli perché non si sa
mai che piova abbiamo un kit di pronto
soccorso poi sveniamo la prima goccia di
sangue o comunque non sappiamo usarla
scatola in fondo al bagagliaio che non
sappiamo più che cosa contengano e così
la nostra mente è talmente intasata di
idee talvolta buone ma sono lì che
rimangono da anni che non riusciamo a
mettere nuove idee non riusciamo più a
liberarcene
la meditazione ha superato tutti i test
di ri procivil ita e di falsificabilità
che sono i test scientifici quindi la
meditazione entra come scienza a tutti
gli effetti una delle scienze della
nostra mente
spesso noi diciamo che non abbiamo tempo
per meditare e per trovare spazio però
la mattina quando ci svegliamo abbiamo
tempo per lavarci di togliere
centinaia migliaia di cellule morte
liberare gli intestini e quindi perché
non abbiamo tempo per liberare un po la
nostra mente lo stesso alla sera quando
rientriamo a casa dovremmo trovare il
tempo per detossificare no per liberare
dalla mente tutti i pensieri e tutto
quello che è accaduto durante la
giornata che non ci servirà più il
giorno dopo un detto zen è una buona
parola tiene un asino legato ad un palo
100 anni sì perché di buone idee e di
creatività ne abbiamo tantissima
soprattutto in italia la difficoltà non
è essere creativi la difficoltà non è
avere buone idee
la vera difficoltà è eliminare le
vecchie idee anche se sono buone ma sono
invecchiate fare spazio nella nostra
mente e la meditazione ci aiuta proprio
questo
tra una mente creativa e una mente non
creativa
sapete qual è la differenza che la mente
creativa è libera totalmente libera
quasi vuota invece la mente non creativa
è ingolfata dei pensieri ingolfata da
tutto quello che è il suo passato e non
riesce a liberarsene
quindi una pratica come la meditazione
anche come lo zen e è stata praticata
come vedete da tantissime persone steve
jobs
john cage leonard cohen ha vissuto tre
anni in un monastero zen
ma la meditazione per tutti non è solo
per lo zero ci sono aziende come
microsoft come google come nike come
deutsche bank numerose aziende hanno
fatto programmi di meditazione per i
loro dipendenti e ancora producono in
italia c'è la branca con niccolò branca
porta personalmente la meditazione
all'interno della sua azienda
quindi la meditazione veramente il il
punto il fulcro sta diventando sempre
più importante le neuroscienze si
occupano sempre di più della meditazione
gli psicologi gli psicanalisti chiunque
si occupi della mente non può non
occuparsi della meditazione e quindi
anche noi dobbiamo trovare un po di
tempo durante il giorno per fermarci
farlo entrare come pratica non solo
detossificante ma come qualità della
nostra vita
se vogliamo veramente stare nel qui e
ora far fronte soprattutto oggi a questa
mutevolezza a questa incandescenza della
vita dobbiamo far entrare la meditazione
che non è un aspetto religioso e
togliamo le candele togliamo gli incensi
togliamo tutto quello che può essere
l'aspetto religioso è un aspetto della
nostra mente
per questo noi giriamo l'italia giriamo
un po tutto il mondo a portare la
pratica della meditazione nella
quotidianità di tutti grazie
[Applauso]